SO HIS GAME JUST CONTINUES TOON.
BUMPED AS HE WAS HEADING
ANDREW COPP.
ALL OF THE WORK ALONG THE
BOARDS.
COPP IS ABLE
6-0-1 LIFETIME AGAINST THE
RANGERS.
>> Sam: HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN TOUGH
AND TOUGH NUMBERS HE PLAYED
LEFT WING ON ST. LOUIS.
MILLER. SUTER.
A FORMER C ZIBANEJAD.
DROP
CHEEKBONE.
WALMAN TRIES TO AVOID THAT BUT
DOWN ON THE ICE BUT HE PLAY.
LAFFICIALS DEEM --
OH, LOOK THAT.
THERE IS CORNER.
VRANA SENDS IT AROUND TOE CHANC!
THEY DO.
A COUPLE OF PASSES ANDTIP-IN. H
STICK.
FOX KEEPS IT IN.
STROME HAS WIDE.
DeKEYSER COMES AWAY WITH IT.
TROUBA BACK ON THE ICE.
THAT WAS QUICK MEDICAL A DEFLEC
INTO THE NETTING.
1:02 TO GO TAKEAWAY BY STROME.
LEAVES I THIS SEASON.
POKED AHEAD BY GOODROW.
THAT WAS
NO HESIT
SEASON PANARIN.
KREIDER SET UP IN FRON THE SHOU.
HAS THE ONLY GOAL OF THE
FRK ON THE PLAY
AND RIPS IT HOME.
THAT WAS A HIT COMING BAC CHYTI.
NOW COPP.
BACK TOSUDDEN, THE RANGERS ARE
ON AN
CHECKED IN THE CORNENERIOD.
RANGERS 3-0 LEAD WITH A GOAL IN.
BETWEEN THE LEGS!DOWN, GREISS.